The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In the previous lectures, we
talked about the basic process
of the incremental solution
that is used in
finite element analysis.
And we talked about quite some
important continuum mechanics
variables that we are employing
in nonlinear finite
element analysis.
This was really preparatory work
for the discussion of a
general formulation that is very
widely used to analyze
nonlinear systems using
finite elements.
And this formulation is called
the total Lagrangian
formulation.
This is the formulation that I'd
like to discuss with you
now in this lecture.
The total Lagrangian formulation
is a formulation
that refers the stress and the
strain variables at time t
plus delta t to the original
configuration at time zero.
Total, in fact, means reference
to the original
configuration here.
And notice we, of course,
encountered this equation
already earlier in the
early lectures.
We have on the left hand side
again the total internal
virtual work.
And on the right hand side,
the total external virtual
work all at time
t plus delta t.
We have here the second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress tensor.
Here we have the Green-Lagrange
strain tensor.
And on the right hand side, of
course, all the body forces,
surface forces et cetera
would enter.
We discussed in a previous
lecture how the right hand
side is calculated in general
and what it all contains.
We also discussed that this
equation here is quite
equivalent to this equation.
And in this equation, we have
the Cauchy stress tensor
operating on the virtual
strain tensor, an
infinitesimally small
strain tensor.
And this product is integrated
over the volume at time
t plus delta t.
On the right hand side,
we have the same
quantity as up there.
Now notice that we really want
to solve, of course, this
equation here in finite
element analysis.
But we discussed earlier that in
order to do so effectively,
we need to introduce a new
stress measure, a new strain
measure, and that, of course,
brings us then to this
equation up here.
Let us recall briefly some of
the important points that we
made earlier in the
other lectures.
We said that this equation here,
applied at time t plus
delta t, is an expression
of the equilibrium,
compatibility, and the
stress-strain law at time t
plus delta t.
Let's just look at this equation
once more, where
these quantities enter.
Well, if equilibrium is
satisfied locally everywhere
in the continuum, then this
equation must be holding for
any virtual displacements that
satisfy the displacement
boundary conditions, and
corresponding virtual strains.
Notice that the virtual
displacements enter on the
right hand side, and these here
are the corresponding
virtual strains.
The compatibility enters in
here because we would, of
course, use compatible virtual
displacement, and we would
calculate also the stresses from
compatible displacements.
The stress-strain law enters
in the calculation of the
stress here from the
strains given.
And once again we apply this
at time t plus delta t.
We also noted earlier that
we will be using
an incremental solution.
Namely, that the solution at
time t plus delta t will be
calculated from the solution at
time t by incrementing the
displacements by ui.
Notice that we will assume,
of course, that
the tui's are known.
That the displacementts at time
t are known, and that
these are the unknown
quantities that
we're looking for.
Of course, that gives us then
the unknown quantities that we
actually want to solve for.
Our goal is, for the finite
element solution to linearize
the equation of the principle
of virtual work, so as to
obtain a set of equations,
finite element equations, that
read as follows.
Here we have a stiffness
matrix, a
tangent stiffness matrix.
Here we have an incremental
displacement vector.
And on the right hand side, we
have a load vector, a vector
of nodal point forces
corresponding to the
externally applied loads
at time t plus delta t.
And here we have a nodal point
force vector that is
equivalent to the current
element stresses, in this
particular instance at time
t, as indicated by the
superscript t here.
Now this incremental
displacement vector, of
course, will be added to the
displacement that we know
already, and that correspond
to time t.
And that will give us then
a first estimate for the
solution, displacement
solution, at time
t plus delta t.
Notice this is also summarized
down here.
Notice, however, that this
vector here is only an
approximation to the actual
vector that we're looking for,
because of the linearization
process that leads us to this
system of equations.
The equation tku equals r
minus f is, of course,
applicable for a single element
as well as a total
assemblage of elements.
In other words, this equation
here, tk delta u1 equals t
plus delta r minus tf, would be
applicable to an element in
which n then would mean just
the degrees of freedom, the
number of degrees of freedom
of that element.
And also for a total structure
in which n then, of course
means the total number of
structural degrees of freedom.
The tk matrix, the r vector,
and the f vector would be
constructed using the direct
stiffness method the way we
are used to it in the linear
elastic analysis.
In other words, there is
nothing new here to be
discussed really, as far as a
construction of these matrices
go, when we talk about a total
element assemblage from the
individual element matrices.
However, an important point
is that we cannot simply
linearize the principle of
virtual work when it is
written in this form here.
And the reason was, of course,
that we cannot integrate over
an unknown volume.
The volume t plus delta t is
unknown, or the volume at time
t plus delta t is unknown, and
we cannot directly increment
the Cauchy stresses the way we
discussed it already earlier.
To linearize then, we need to
choose a known reference
configuration.
And one known reference
configuration that is a very
natural one to use really,
is the one
corresponding to time zero.
In this case, if we use that
reference configuration, we
talk about the total Lagrangian
formulation.
If we use as a reference
configuration the
configuration corresponding to
time t, then we talk about the
updated Lagrangian
formulation.
I'd like to make
one point here.
Namely, that of course we have
calculated already from all
the configurations from
time zero to time t.
So you may ask yourself, why
is he not choosing as a
reference configuration, for
example, the configuration t
minus delta t?
In other words, one
configuration prior to time t
as a possibility.
Well, it would be a possibility,
but if you choose
to do so, you would lose the
advantages that you have in
the updated Lagrangian
formulation, and the
advantages that you would have
in the total Lagrangian
formulation.
Of course, there are differences
here and we will
talk about the advantages and
disadvantages of either of
these formulations.
And you would be left with that
choice of t minus delta t
reference configuration,
with basically all the
disadvantages only.
And therefore, we generally want
to choose either this one
or that one as the reference
configuration.
Let us now discusses the total
Lagrangian formulation.
In the total Lagrangian
formulation, we use the
reference configuration zero,
and therefore we talk about
this stress.
We use this stress and that
strain, this was a second
Piola-Kirchhoff stress referred
to the configuration
at time zero.
This is the Green-Lagrange
strain referred to the
configuration at time zero.
The principle of virtual work
once again, originally in this
form, is now written
in this form.
We have had that already before
on viewgraphs, and I
don't think I need to go through
those details again.
But the important point is
that this is the starting
point of the total Lagrangian
formulation.
The formulation proceeds
as follows.
We know the solution at time t,
therefore this stress, this
displacement derivative, all
the static and kinematic
variables in fact, are known
corresponding to the
configuration at time t.
And we can now decompose the
stress corresponding to time t
plus delta t into one known
value and one unknown value.
Similarly we proceed with
the strain measures.
The strain measures, the
Green-Lagrange strain at time
t plus delta t is decomposed
into one value that we know
already, and an increment.
And, of course, remember these
two increments are unknown.
They are unknown, whereas these
are known because we
have calculated already
the configuration
corresponding to time t.
In terms of displacements, we
can directly develop that the
Green-Lagrange strain at time
t is written as shown here.
We went over these different
components already earlier.
Notice once again that we have
a product of displacement
derivatives here,
that this is, of
course, a nonlinear term.
And once again, as I pointed out
in an earlier lecture, we
have nothing neglected here.
You see only quadratic terms.
There are no cubic terms
or higher-order terms.
We have nothing neglected.
This is a strain measure that
holds for any amount of
deformation, any amount
of strain.
Then we can also write this same
strain, Green-Lagrange
strain, corresponding to time t
plus delta t, and this would
be the result.
Notice whatever we had here as t
superscript has now become a
t plus delta t superscript.
That's in fact the
only difference.
If you subtract from this
strain, that strain, we get
the increment, and
that increment is
written out right here.
Now, there are some interesting
points regarding
this incremental strain.
This here is an increment in the
strain that is linear in
the displacement components.
Similarly this one.
Notice this one here, is, of
course a product, product and
may look, at first sight,
as a nonlinear term.
When you see products of
displacements, you think of a
nonlinearity.
However, if you look closer,
you find that
there is a t here.
Therefore, this part is known.
Since this part is known, and
this part is unknown, this
total term is really linear in
the incremental displacement.
In fact, the incremental
displacements don't even go in
here, because we're
differentiating here the
displacements at time t with
respect to the original
coordinates.
Therefore, this total
term here is really
still linear in ui.
Linear in the incremental
displacements.
We call this part here, as
given here, the initial
displacement effect.
The initial displacement effect
because the initial
displacements go into these
derivatives here.
We are differentiating the
displacement at time t with
respect to the original
coordinates.
This term, on the other hand
here, is nonlinear in ui.
It is nonlinear because here
we're taking one term that
depends on ui, and we multiply
it by another term that
depends on ui.
Notice this a differentiation
of uk, the incremental
displacement, into the k
direction with respect to the
original coordinates.
Coordinate axis xj
here particular.
So this is here, clearly
a nonlinear term in ui.
A quadratic term, as
a matter of fact.
We will look at this strain,
of course, a little
bit more just now.
But keep in mind that there is
one linear term that contains
an initial displacement effect
and a nonlinear term.
I might add here that, of
course, this initial
displacement effect is
zero if the initial
displacements are zero.
In other words, in our
incremental solution, for
example, if we are just starting
the solution process,
then the initial displacements
are still zero.
This term drops out.
We note now regarding the
formulation that the variation
on the total Green-Lagrange
strain tensor corresponding to
time t plus delta t, is really
equal to the variation in the
increment of the Green-Lagrange
strain tensor,
from time t to time
t plus delta t.
In this picture we show
what we mean by that.
Here on the left hand side in
black, you have the body in
its original configuration.
It moves to a configuration
at time t.
And then to a configuration,
here shown in green, that
corresponds to time
t plus delta t.
Notice here we have the
displacement corresponding to
time t, and then the
displacement corresponding
from time t to time
t plus delta t.
The total displacement,
of course, here is the
displacement from time zero
to time t plus delta t.
What we are doing, of course
in the principle of virtual
work, is to impose a variation
in displacements about the
configuration at time
t plus delta t.
And that variation is here
indicated by the blue line.
And if we impose this variation
here, since the
displacements at time t are
constant, surely whatever
these displacements were
should not matter.
And that is, in fact,
expressed by this
relationship here.
If we vary here, since the
displacements to ui are
constant, they do not affect the
variation on the strains.
And therefore, we can simply
vary the incremental strain,
and we find that variation is
indeed equal to the variation
of the total strain.
Of course, you can also
prove that to yourself
mathematically by just going
through the arithmetic.
In other words, applying the
variation to this quantity,
and then applying the variation
to that quantity,
which I've given you on the
previous viewgraph, and you
would find that indeed you
get identically the same
expressions.
We can define a linear strain
term, linear strain increment,
as 0 eij, and the nonlinear
strain increment as 0 eta ij.
Notice that once again, here we
have the quadratic terms.
And, of course, when we add
these two terms together, we
get back our total strain
increment from time t to time
t plus delta t.
If we take a variation on that
increment, that is equivalent
to taking a variation on
the linear term and
the nonlinear term.
Notice that so far we
have only talked
about continuum mechanics.
Of course we want to use the
continuum mechanics principles
that we discussed so far
in the finite element
discretization.
But notice that these strain
terms here that we talked
about, are really continuum
mechanics variables.
There is an interesting
observation.
Namely, if we talk about this
strain measure and that strain
measure, rather the linear
incremental strains and the
nonlinear incremental strains,
linear and nonlinear in ui,
then if we apply these in finite
element analysis, we
have to remember that the
displacements are interpolated
in terms of nodal
point variables.
And what we're really looking
for in finite element analysis
are the nodal points
variables.
In isoparametric finite element
analysis, which is the
final element procedure that we
will be using extensively,
we interpolate the internal
element displacements, tui, in
terms of the nodal point
displacements.
Let me define a little bit
more what this is here.
This is, of course, the
displacement from time zero to
time t into the i's direction.
We are summing here over all
the finite element nodal
points, the N nodal points.
We have interpolation functions,
hk, that we will
talk more about later on.
And we have here the nodal point
displacement at time t
into the i direction of
the nodal point k.
This k goes with that k.
And we're summing over
all the nodal points.
Now notice that this is the
linear relationship in
isoparametric finite
element analysis of
solids, I should say.
This is a linear relationship.
And therefore, our linear strain
terms that we talked
earlier about, being linear in
the incremental continuum
mechanics displacements, are
also linear in the incremental
nodal point displacements.
Similarly, this term here, which
was nonlinear in the
increments of displacements
within the domain, from a
continuum mechanics point of
view, will also be nonlinear
in the nodal point displacement
increments.
However, in the formulation of
structural elements, with the
incremental displacements,
in fact also the total
displacements, I interpolated
using nodal point
displacements and nodal
point rotations.
In other words, we also deal
with nodal point rotations in
order to calculate the total
displacements of the element.
And in that case, we have to
recognize that the exact
linear strain increment, the way
we have defined it earlier
linear in the incremental
displacements, is still
properly given as a linear
strain increment in the nodal
point variables.
However, the term that we
defined earlier as a nonlinear
strain increment, this one, is
not the full story of all the
nonlinear strain increments.
Because the rotations will put
additional nonlinear strain
increments into this
term here.
The reason being, that for large
rotations, of course, we
have cosine sine terms in these
rotations and when we
evaluate the total nonlinear
strain term, we find that
there are additional terms
coming up here.
Well, what is the effect of
these two statements?
It means that the right hand
side force vector, or rather
the vector t 0 f, the vector
of nodal point forces
corresponding to the internal
elements stresses, is always
correctly calculated.
However, the stiffness matrix,
t 0 k, for the formulation is
only approximated because some
of the nonlinear terms here
have been dropped in the case
of structural elements.
Of course, you can also include
the nonlinear terms.
Then you would have to add these
terms to this expression
here, and then you would get a
true tangent stiffness matrix.
This means, of course, for an
actual analysis, that when you
form the equations, we have on
the left hand side-- let me
just put all of it in here--
for the first iteration, we
talked about the fact that we
have a stiffness matrix times an
increment in displacements.
I already put a 1 there because
it will be only an
approximation to the
total incremental
displacement vector.
Well, we notice then that this
matrix here is approximated if
you were to drop these
additional terms.
But the right hand side vector f
here is properly calculated.
Therefore if you iterate, you
always get the exact solution,
the correct solution.
But the convergence in the
iteration might be a bit
slower than what you could
have obtained if you had
included these additional terms
here that I referred to.
Let us now continue with
the continuum mechanics
formulation.
The equation of the principle of
virtual work becomes, if we
substitute the quantities that
I defined earlier, directly
this equation.
Notice here we have now the
increment in stress times the
variation of the incremental
Green-Lagrange strain, from
time t to t plus delta t.
Of course, it's integrated over
the original volume plus
this integral here.
Here we have the total stress,
second Piola-Kirchhoff stress,
corresponding to time t
operating on the nonlinear
strain increment of the total
Green-Lagrange strain increment.
And once again, we are
integrating over the total
volume corresponding
to time zero.
And on the right hand side, we
have the external virtual work
minus the stress at time t,
operating on the linear strain
increment corresponding
to the total
Green-Lagrange strain increment.
We have so far made no
approximations, and this is a
relationship that has to hold
for any arbitrary variation in
displacements which go in here,
or any arbitrary virtual
displacement that go in here.
And of course, corresponding
strains that appear here.
In essence, what we have been
doing is that we have
established a variation on
the configuration at time
t plus delta t.
We have looked at the principle
of virtual work
corresponding to time t plus
delta t, but we have
introduced this increment
in displacement.
Notice that this increment in
displacement is measured from
the displacement at time t.
All we have done therefore, is
to rewrite the principle of
virtual work in terms of tu and
u instead of dealing with
t plus delta tu.
No approximation being
done yet so far.
Of course, we really haven't
been talking about finite
elements either yet, when we
just look at this basic
equation of principle
of virtual work.
It is this principle or the
equation that we are dealing
with, is in general, a very
complicated function of the
unknown displacement
increment.
We obtain an approximate
relationship in finite element
analysis, by linearizing the
governing equation, and, of
course, then in the finite
element sense cast it into
this set of linear equations.
The process of linearizing is
a very important process,
interesting process for us
to study, and that's what
I want to do now.
We begin to look, in this
linearization at all the
individual terms that appear
in the integral.
And let us look first
at this term here.
This term is actually already
linear in ui.
So there is nothing
much to linearize.
t 0 sij does not contain ui.
It's a known quantity.
It's a known stress value.
And notice that when we take
the variation on this
nonlinear strain increment, we
directly get this expression,
where this part here is
a variation on the
displacement increment.
Similarly here.
And of course, these are
going to be constants.
Therefore, this term here is
linear in the incremental
displacements.
Linear in ui.
So nothing to linearize there.
The term on this viewgraph here,
contains an incremental
stress and an incremental
strain.
Notice this incremental strain
contains the linear and the
nonlinear term.
And this, of course, this
product is a linear functional
off ui, sorry it contains
linear terms,
nonlinear terms as well.
This stress here is, in general,
a nonlinear function
of 0 epsilon ij.
The variation that we are
taking here means we are
taking a variation on
the linear part and
the nonlinear part.
We will see actually that this
one here is constant.
But this one carries also terms
of ui, so this total
expression is linear in ui.
And if we multiply these terms
here, we want to end up in
just one expression that has
neglected all higher-order
terms in ui, but just
contains ui.
Well, let us do so.
The objective is expressed
once more here, and we
recognize that, of course, the
variation on 0 epsilon ij
contains only constant and
linear terms in ui, the way I
just expressed it.
0 sij can be written as a Taylor
series expansion in 0
epsilon ij.
This is the general
expression.
Here we take the partial of
the stress at time t, with
respect to the Green-Lagrange
strain at time t, here we are
having this bar with the t
that denotes that we are
actually doing this evaluation
at time t.
And here we have an increment in
this strain, and of course,
there are higher-order terms.
These higher-order terms we will
neglect, and therefore we
get directly for this stress
here, this expression.
Notice we already have
substituted for 0 epsilon rs,
these two quantities.
This one here is quadratic in
ui, this one is linear in ui.
And if we linearize this term,
we get directly this one here.
Notice that this is the
appropriate stress-strain law
that has to be used
corresponding
to this stress measure.
And we will later on talk more
about how we evaluate this
stress-strain law.
As an example, we may look
here at this schematic
solution, computed solution,
over a number of time steps.
We're going time 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, up to t minus delta
t and then to t.
The stress-strain law relates
basically the stress increment
here to the strain increment.
And notice it represents a
tangent to this this curve.
This green line here is a
tangent to the red or the blue
curve, the blue one now
overlapping the red curve
right there.
So we have here the tangent, or
the slope of this tangent
is giving us the material
tensor 0c.
Of course, here we're talking
just about one element.
In general we have many elements
corresponding to the
strain and stress measures
that we are dealing with.
If we now substitute the result
that we just looked at
into the general equation--
sorry to take this one down--
into the general equation here,
we see directly that
this part here, of course,
is the stress.
And this part here gives
us that part.
We simply multiply out and look
at the individual terms.
We notice that this one
does not contain ui.
is linear in ui.
So since this one is already
linear in ui, this term will
be quadratic in ui.
We will have to drop it.
This term here is linear in ui,
but this one is constant,
so this total term
is linear in ui.
And this is the one we keep,
and which is then the
linearized result.
In other words, in summary once
more, this total term
here linearized is obtained
via this expression here.
The final linearized equation
that we are then dealing with,
now that we're substituting
all these results into the
original equation that we have
developed, is as follows.
Here we have one term that comes
from the incremental
stress times the variation
on the total incremental
Green-Lagrange strain.
That all has reduced
to this term.
Here we did not have to
linearize at all.
We kept what we already had.
And on the right hand side,
did not linearize either,
because this was a term that we
had already there, and of
course this is the external
virtual work.
Now it's interesting to note
that these two terms here
result into this expression,
where this is the tangent
stiffness matrix.
Notice that tangent stiffness
matrix contains the material
tensor, as well as the
current stresses.
This incremental displacement
here, vector, comes from this
strain part and that
strain part.
Notice that this virtual
displacement vector here comes
from that strain part and
also from that one here.
Below here we have, of course,
that the external virtual work
results into a vector of nodal
point forces times these
virtual displacements.
And this one here results into
the force vector corresponding
to the internal element
stresses.
And this is, of course, a very
important quantity that we
have to calculate accurately,
as I pointed out earlier.
Because we want ultimately in
the iteration that this vector
is equilibriating that vector,
and if we do make a mistake in
calculating this vector, then
we might have converged, but
we have converged to
the wrong solution.
So it's very important to
recognize that this vector
must be accurately calculated,
by all means.
However, the k matrix here, if
we go back once more to the
discussion of this matrix, the
k matrix here is a tangent
stiffness matrix.
And this tangent stiffness
matrix is selected such as to
obtain, of course, in the
incremental solution, an
appropriate incremental
displacement.
We will see later on
that this matrix is
updated in the iteration.
It depends on what kind of
intuitive scheme we are using,
depending on that scheme we
are updating this matrix
differently.
In any case, it's a matrix that
we will in quotes, "play
around with", in order to
accelerate the convergence.
Therefore there is no unique
matrix that can be used here,
that should be used here.
There are different
possibilities that we will
discuss in later lectures.
But on the right hand side once
again, this F vector is
the F vector obtained from the
current stresses, and that one
has to be calculated uniquely
in the correct way.
Well, an important point is that
this relationship here on
the left hand side, is equal to
the relationship given here
on the right hand side.
And this holds because
this term here is
equal to that term.
We interpret, in fact, this
right hand side as an out of
balance virtual work term.
Let's look once why this holds,
because this might be a
bit of a surprise.
The mathematical explanation
is given on this viewgraph.
We had earlier already that
the variation on the total
Green-Lagrange strain is
nothing else than the
variation on the incremental
total Green-Lagrange strain.
Now if we look down here, we
recognize that this variation
here at ui equal to 0, is
nothing else than the
variation on the Green-Lagrange
strain at time t.
If ui is zero, then this term
here is nothing else than the
Green-Lagrange strain
at time t.
So we're looking here at
the variation of the
Green-Lagrange at time, t
if I put ui equal to 0.
Now let's look at these
expressions here.
If I evaluate this term here, at
ui equal to 0, we find that
this term here, being a
constant, is recovered.
But notice that this term here,
with ui equal to 0,
simply turns out to be 0.
Therefore, this term is
equal to that term.
And this means, therefore, that
the variation on t zero
epsilon ij is equal to the
variation on 0 eij, which we
wanted to prove, of course.
So this is the reason why this
term here is equal to that
term, as we have used it on
the previous viewgraph.
This result also makes physical
sense, because if we
look at the governing equation,
we find that this
term here, replaced, is
nothing else than tr.
Should be tr.
And of course, the script
r the external virtual
work at time t.
And this, of course, is here the
out of balance load term.
Now if, for example, the
material is elastic, and the
external virtual work has not
changed, then clearly the
displacements would
not change.
In other words, t plus delta tui
would be equal to tui, and
the incremental displacements
would be 0.
Therefore, equilibrium
would be satisfied.
Hence, this term, which we have
here, must actually be
equal to t 0 sij times variation
t 0 epsilon ij, the
way we discussed it just now.
We may rewrite the linearized
governing equation as given on
this viewgraph.
And I am rewriting it in this
form because we anticipate
that we need an iteration.
We simply introduce here, an
iteration counter 1, with the
delta in front of the
incremental strain value.
And similarly we introduce a
delta here, and an iteration
counter 1 there.
And on the right hand side, we
introduce also an iteration
counter, but one lower.
In other words, 0 here, whereas
we have a 1 there.
Notice 0 here, a 1 here.
And notice furthermore, that
this term is nothing else than
that term, and this term here
is nothing else than the
variation on t 0 epsilon ij.
This would be the equation
that we have developed
already, just having introduced
now a different
notation which leads us towards
what we want to deal
with in the iteration.
The governing equations from a
finite element point of view,
then would be as shown here.
Notice tangent stiffness matrix,
del u1, iteration
counter, the external loads,
which we still assume to be
constant, by the way.
We still assume deformation
independent loading if we have
deformation dependent loading,
these would also
change in the iteration.
And here we have the vector
corresponding to the internal
element stresses at time t.
We write that vector as t
plus delta t 0, 0 there.
And that means that we are
really talking, at this point,
about this vector.
We calculate this incremental
displacement vector and add it
to the previous displacements,
which, of course, in this
particular instance, in the
first iteration, are nothing
else than tu.
We add those, and obtain
our first estimates of
displacements, namely the
estimate at the end of
iteration 1.
Having obtained now this
estimate on displacements, we
can repeat the process.
And that is shown here on
the next viewgraph.
Notice that now I am talking
about the right hand side,
about the Green-Lagrange strains
corresponding to time
t plus delta t, and the
first iteration.
In other words, these are the
Green-Lagrange strains
corresponding to the end
of the first iteration.
They include now the incremental
displacements that
we just calculated.
Similarly, these are the
stresses corresponding to the
end of the first iteration.
And this is an out of balance
virtual work term.
If that is non-zero, we will
have further increment in
displacements.
And that increment results,
of course, into an
increment of strains.
Namely, the second increment.
Here is the 2 that denotes
the increment.
The finite element equations
then would look as shown here.
Same equation as before,
but now with a 1
here and a 2 there.
We calculate the incremental
displacements, we add them to
what we had already and get a
better approximation to the
displacements corresponding
to time t plus delta t.
This process, of course, can now
be repeated, and on this
viewgraph we show how
it's being done for
every iteration k.
In a particular iteration, we
have now on the right hand
side the external virtual work
corresponding to time t plus
delta t, the stresses
delta t and iteration
k minus 1.
At the end of iteration
k minus 1, the strains
corresponding to time t plus
delta t, and at the end of
iteration k minus 1.
This is the out of balance
virtual work term, and on the
left hand side we have the same
quantities as before, but
now with the iteration
counter k.
When discretized, we obtain
these equations here.
Delta uk, the increment in the
iteration k of displacements,
r minus f, computed, of course,
from the current
displacements.
From the current displacements
we calculate that vector here.
Notice this vector is obtained
from this integral here.
We repeat this process for
iteration k 1, 2, 3 et cetera
until convergence.
We will have to talk about
how we measure
convergence and so on.
But in this iteration we're
adding up the total
incremental displacements to
obtain always a better
estimate for the displacements
corresponding to time t plus
delta t, and here, of
course, iteration k.
Notice that the counter here
goes from j equals 1 to k,
that is this j and this k, of
course, is nothing else than
the k that we have on the
left hand side here.
Notice once again that the first
iteration, when k is
equal to 1, it amounts to
nothing else than what we
discussed already at the very
beginning a little earlier in
the lecture.
We simply generalized that
discussion now to an equation
in which we iterate and always
try to calculate another
increment in displacements
until the right
hand side is 0.
Notice when the right hand
side is 0, the external
virtual work is equilibrated by
the internal virtual work,
and of course, that is what
we want to reach.
That is what our criterion
is for the analysis.
The external virtual work must
be equilibrated by the
internal virtual work.
In the finite element
discretization, the whole
process is as summarized
on this viewgraph.
Initially, we are given
tu, the displacements
corresponding to time t, and the
externally applied loads
corresponding to time
t plus delta t.
We compute the stiffness matrix,
the tangent stiffness
matrix corresponding
to time t.
We calculate this vector,
the nodal point forces
corresponding to the
stresses at time t.
Notice this 0 here refers always
to the total Lagrangian
formulation.
Notice that this vector here
is really the initial
condition for the iteration.
Similar, the displacements
at time t are the initial
conditions for the iteration
for the displacements.
Zero here.
Zero there, meaning the initial
conditions for our iteration.
We set the iteration counter,
k equal to 1, and we now go
into the following loop.
Notice on the right hand side,
an out of balance load vector
is calculated.
And that out of balance load
vector gives us an incremental
displacement vector.
Of course, the tangent stiffness
matrix is involved
in that calculation.
Notice that this incremental
displacement vector is added
to the displacements that we had
previously calculated, to
obtain a new estimate on
the displacements.
And like that, we have now
obtained a displacement vector
that, of course, hopefully is
closer to satisfying certain
convergence criteria.
We will have to talk about
these convergence
criteria later on.
Basically, we check whether
equilibrium is satisfied
within a certain tolerance.
If the equilibrium is not
satisfied, we go here.
We use these displacements that
we just have calculated
to compute a new vector
of nodal point forces
corresponding to the
element stresses.
Notice this vector now contains
the information that
we have just calculated in
solving this equation here.
This was information
that we obtained.
And that information is
contained in this vector, and
that vector is used right here
to calculate this nodal point
force vector.
Having calculated that, we
increase our iteration
counter, come back here and
like that we continue the
iteration, looping around
through here
as I have just described.
Notice at convergence once
again, we want, of course,
that r is equal to f, meaning
that the external loads are
equilibrated by the nodal point
forces corresponding to
the internal element stresses.
Well, this brings us to the
end of this lecture.
You might recognize that this
last viewgraph really contains
a lot of information that, of
course, we discussed in this
lecture, but that also I
referred to already in the
first lecture.
At that time, I tried to
introduce you to this
iteration process using rather
physical concepts, not going
through a lengthy mathematical
derivation.
We did not talk about continuum
mechanics variables.
We did not talk about total
Lagrangian formulation, second
Piola-Kirchhoff stresses,
Green-Lagrange
strains and so on.
I hoped at that time to give
you just a physical feel of
how we are iterating.
The same kind of equations, the
same equations we looked
at at that time, now I hope
with this lecture, I have
given you the mathematical
basis of these equations.
I hope you have learned how to
derive these equations, how to
work with these equations
a little bit.
And in some of the next
lectures, we will look at how
actually we do construct
this k matrix
for different elements.
That is, of course, a very
important consideration.
How do we calculate this
k matrix for 1D, 2D, 3D
elements, shell elements,
beam elements?
How do we calculate this
force vector for
these different elements?
We will have to discuss
that as well.
Notice that in this k matrix
goes the material law.
Whether we are dealing with an
elasto-plastic material,
rubber type material, all that
will affect the actual
ingredients, the
actual elements
here in that k matrix.
We we also have to discuss how
we can possibly make this
convergence that I'm
talking about fast.
In other words, how can we
accelerate the convergence of
these iterations?
So in essence, I like to just
convey to you that what you
see here you will see a
number of times again.
We will talk about the different
parts that you have
been looking at here already
briefly once again in the
upcoming lectures.
Thank you very much for
your attention.